stir en discothèque on doit se
confronter au fameux videur non mais je
t'aime beaucoup frérot mais là c'est
compliqué là regarde comment il jamais
de la V et parfois la nuit les esprits
peuvent très vite s'échauffer le yarle à
la tête d'un établissement de nuit
affirme même constater une hausse
significative de la délinquence je me
suis rendu compte que dans toutes les
grandes villes de France c'était devenu
très très compliqué de passer d'un point
à un point B sans se faire
agresser alors celui qui est aussi coach
de MMA et qui partage son quotidien à
ses près de 200000 abonnés sur TikTok
n'hésite pas à afficher des agresseurs
sur les réseaux sociaux une méthode
décrier mais qui porte ses fruits selon
lui systématiquement cette action me
permet de récupérer les noms des auteurs
en moins de 24 heures le yarle directeur
d'une boîte de nuit affiche les
délinquants sur les réseaux sociaux
a-t-il raison le Yar te
salue merci le yarle d'être avec nous
directeur adjoint d'une discothèque àen
20 millions de vues accumulé 190000
abonnés sur TikTok 34600 sur X et 33000
sur Facebook le yarn ça veut dire chef
de guerre en scandinave c'est bien ça
exactement et steamorol ça veut dire
chewingum c'est important de le signaler
ça fait longtemps 30 ans ça fait 30 ans
que je suis dans le milieu de la nuit
j'ai commencé à 19 ans ouais et vous
avez senti une évolution j'ai changé
j'ai surtout senti un très gros
changement oui gros changement sur le
comportement des gens la façon dont ils
se comportte en terme général quoi
socialement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner des exemples des exemples
concrets les comportements de certains
groupes en fait il y a des groupes qui
arrivent et puis c'est compliqué les
groupes on on évolué en 30 ans c'est pas
c'était pas un peu pareil ouais ça pas
toujours été un peu comme ça non non non
ça a vraiment changé en fait on la la ce
qui a vraiment changé c'est la forme de
la violence qui est devenue je le dis
tout le temps mais c'est l'extrême
violence on a toujours eu des bagarres
en discothèque tout le temps à 30 ans on
a toujours des barilm préféré c'est
radous r ah ouis
Dalton je suis pas Dalton
mais la vra c'est V a toujours des
bagarres en boî de nuit a toujours eu
des bagarres en boîte de nuit il y a
toujours eu des effets groupe il y a il
y a toujours eu des comportements un peu
compliqués à gérer la différence
aujourd'hui c'est le degré de violence
qui a vraiment vraiment changé et il y a
aussi ce qui entoure les établissements
de nuit surtout en ville c'est ça qui a
vraiment changé avant on avait pas tout
ça à gérer c'est que en plus de gérer
les établissements de nuit c'est que
l'intérieur on a les extérieurs qui
doivent être gérés je parle bien en
grande ville parce que les extérieurs et
ben on attire tout un tas de personnes
qui veulent faire du business autour les
établissements et c'est ça qui a qui m'a
rendu la tâche très difficile parce que
gérer un endroit faire devenir un
endroit sécure c'est facile en
discothèque quand on a les bons les bons
partenaires de de travail tous les
portiers font un excellent travail et
tout VO quand on a les bons ça se fait
c'est facile gérer les extérieurs ça
devient plus compliqué parce que les
extérieurs c'est pas de notre ressort
c'est du ressort de la police c'est du
ressort des mairies enfin voilà c'est
c'est à eux de gérer les extérieurs des
établissements des endroits où il y a
des forts passages et puis
malheureusement ça devient tellement
compliqué tellement fréquent les vol les
deals les bagarres pour arracher un
téléphone arracher un portefeuille c'est
devenu tellement fréquent et tellement
violent qu'il a fallu je trouve des
solutions pour régler ce problème là
alors justement vous avez décidé
d'afficher sur les réseaux sociaux les
les les les ceux qui les fauteurs de
trouble j'ai envie de dire les
délinquants les fauteurs de trouble moi
je dirais plus est-ce que c'est efficace
de les afficher c'est très efficace
alors faut bien comprendre que je suis
passé par des étapes avant de faire ça
c'est j'ai pas fait direct je vais les
tous les afficher en fait j'ai testé
plein de choses avant euh quand on
sortait avec les gars et qu'on voyait
que ça devenait systématiquement brutal
quelqu'un qui vole un portable ou
portefeuille s'il arrive pas à le faire
de toute façon il utilise la violence et
ils viennent sur nous à plusieurs parce
qu'ils sont très organisés c'est pour
eux il faut bien comprendre que c'est un
métier c'est comme ça qu' qu' qui
gagnent leur vie c'est pas facile à
comprendre quand on le vit pas mais
quand on est sur le terrain on le voit
constamment la police le sa de toute
façon par cœur puisque c'est aussi leur
quotidien le problème c'est que j'ai
constaté très vite que les 18 25 ans
étaient les premières victimes de ces
gens-là en fait mais quand je vous dis
victime c'est pas juste une claque la
première année où j'étais dans cet
établissement à la direction j'ai vu des
jeunes vraiment mais se faire déglinguer
par C si gars et et et puis ressortir le
temps qu'on arrive c'est trop tard ils
sont marqués de partout il y a un mois
d'arrê d'arrêt enfin un mois d'ité céit
une catastrophe moi j'ai deux filles il
y en a une qui travaille avec vous les
deux ouais on travaille en famille tout
le monde travaille on a toujours
travaillé depuis tout le temps on a tout
le temps travaillé en famille en fait et
donc j'ai ma fille que vous connaissez
qui est déjà venue sur le plateau TPMP
qui s'appelle Lili pour d'autres raisons
ouais elle était c'était une la plus
jeune femme
qui faisait des combats de MMA en France
et vous l'avez vous l'aviez reçu Lili
elle avait d'ailleurs fait un
étranglement à Moktar elle a toujours la
vidéo elle était passée sur votre dos
elle a fait ce qu'on appelle une mat il
s'en
souvient et elle elle est physio à
l'entrée ma deuxème fille elle est au
niveau des bars d'accord voilà vous
travaillez en famille alors il y en a
qui sont pas du tout d'accord avec vous
méthode vous doutez bien que Gill Verdez
bien sûr pas d'accord avec vous voilà
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on l'écoute tout
de suite Gill Verdez ou bien on laisse
d'abord les autres tiens j'ai d'abord
envie d'attendre allez tu as envie de
parler oui j'aimerais bien bah ne crie
pas tu viens de réveiller maie tu es
tranquillement en train de dormir toutes
l'émission tu la réveilles maintenant
allez vas-y non je me suis intéressé de
très près à votre initiative au début je
trouvais ça loable mais tu aimes pas ça
et puis après tuaim pas ça puisque tu
aimes pas les les même les commerçants
qui mettent les photos des des des
voleurs je me suis intéressé oui mais
tout ce qu'il fait non j'aime pas qu'on
affiche mais à tout ce qu'il fait c'est
déc ou bien sûr non mais ça on va
revenirus ça j'aime pas l'affichage non
non mais
calme-toiuseo je pas ta mère je peux le
sortir si non mais non mais juste tu
n'aimes pas ça Mo moi personnellement je
suis pour oui je sais sais je suis pour
parce que j'ai vu des commerçants ici
qui qui en pouvait plus et qui se font
voler toute la journée et je vais te
dire le problème qu'il y a c'est que tu
as bien vu de toute façon les mecs qu'on
les mecs qu'on va attraper derrière 40
après ils sont dehors ils vont revoler à
côté donc à un moment bon autant que les
autant que les commerçants sachent qui
sont les gars qui V on les volé au moins
qu'il ont qu' déjà laffiche alors lui il
fait la même chose pour pour les les les
les les ceux quiut les fauteurs de
trouble j'ai envie de dire en boîte de
nuit notamment moi moi je suis en fait
euh je je je sais que est-ce que c'est
illégal ça déjà afficher c'est
totalement illégal on a pas le droit oui
bah donc voilà mais moi ce qui me gêne
derrière tout ça c'est que monsieur se
masque monsieur il est proche de la là
il a juste des lunettes alors il est
proche de la mouvance identitaire il a
le droit mais j'ai lu et écouté toutes
vos déclarations je vous en citez une le
problème souvent c'est avec les
maghrébains de 18 à 25 ans c'est avec
eux que ça se passe mal donc moi ma
question à est clair la rakaille c'est
les Arabes la rakaille c'est pas je dis
jamais la rakaille c'est les Arabes je
dis les groupes non la rakaille c'est
vous qui avez dit la rakaille c'est les
Arabes moi je dis jamais la rakaille
c'est les Arabes je dis le problème il y
a des effets de groupe et j'en parle
mais ouvertement et je leur dis à eux
aussi d'ailleurs je n'ai jamais un
maghrébain qui vient me traiter de
raciste he il me dit jamais ça
j'explique qu'en effet de groupe les les
Maghrébins je dis pas que les Maghrébins
d'ailleurs je je suis d'origine croate
je parle aussi des pays de pays de l'Est
faut pas oublier de le dire donc les
pays j'ai entendu les Maghrébins mais et
les pays de l'Est voilà les pays de
l'Est et les Maghrébins les gens des
pays de l'Est viennent souvent bande
aussi pareil voilà c'est très
communautaire et quand j'allais j' en
boî moi aussi j' jeis en bande ouais
ouais je suis un peu
maghrébin donc les maghrébains issu de
certains quartiers où les règles où ils
ont une zone de territoire je parle pas
de tous les magrbins je travaille avec
des Maghrébins j'en enuchche mais je
parle bien de ceux qui se tiennent mal
et quand ils arrivent en bande un avec
un effet de groupe ils ont toujours
l'impression que l'endroit où ils
arrivent tout leur est dû et leur
comportement doit doit doit passer
l'étape de toutes les règles qu'on met
en place et en fait je leur explique que
c'est pas possible en fait les règles ce
sont celles de l'établissement et que
c'est pas parce que par exemple ils ont
une bouteille à un endroit qui vont
pouvoir faire comme ils veulent à
l'endroit où on leur a mis une bouteille
c'est plus leur territoire c'est quand
même l'endroit où on est et quand il y a
un un effet de violence qui arrive les
magrébin ont une autre façon de faire
qu'avec par exemple les gens européens
mais ça je vais pas vous raconter
pourquoi ça va être un peu long je il y
a des vidéos où je l'explique mais c'est
anthropologique et donc il y a il y a
une réaction qui fait que au niveau de
leur communauté il ne se lâchent pas
même quand quelqu'un a fait un peu une
grosse connerie mais il ne se lâche pas
du tout il reste quand même des frères
je leur en veux pas moi j'ai la haine de
personne vous dites identitaire moi je
vous le dis moi je le dis dans toutes
mes vidéos je j'ai la Haide de personne
il faut juste que je règle des problèmes
de violence et donc les problèmes de
violence je les ai j'ai trouvé des
solutions pour les régler pas des des
solutions qui peuvent être fait sur plan
national ça j'en doute pas parce que
c'est compliqué mais en attendant au
niveau de mon entourage de
l'établissement et ce que j'y fais ça
fonctionne les maghrébains en groupe en
discothèque ça peut être un problème
quand on ne connaît personne dès qu'on
connaît quelqu'un dès qu'on en connaît
au moins un sur un groupe pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai plein de magrbin vous
savez j'ai une sal Hipop Gill la sal
Hipop le gros de la clientèle c'est les
maghrébains et c'est les c'est les
Blacks d'accord voilà c'est le gros de
ma clientèle dans la salle Hipop dans la
salle techno le gros de ma clientèle
j'ai beaucoup d'homo beaucoup de gay
beaucoup de filles avec des cheveux
bleus voilà c'est en techno c'est comme
ça notre discothèque est multiculturel
pas une salle guinguette pour Daniel je
je peux en faire j'ai une salle
généraliste Daniel voilà donc je je je
mets tout le monde au même endroit
multiculturel je peux pas faire mieux
hip hop techn généraliste Gilles
honnêtement bah vous stigmatisez les
Maghrébins j'ai pris une PHAs sur les
musulmans qui est redoutable sur qui sur
les musulmans vous ne trouverez jamais
une vidéo où je parle des musulmans
j'invite les musulmans qui se tiennent
bien à trouver un leader
entenducoup mus c'est vous qui tradz ça
je ne parle jamais écoutez-moi je ne
parle jamais de
musulmans sauf quand je leur dis de nous
aider de nous aider à régler le problème
exuse-moi vous mentez
là j'invite les musulmans qui se
tiennent bien à prendre une posture et à
trouver un leader vous l' dit oui comme
je l'ai encore dit hier musulmans qui se
tienent
mal ma dernière vidéo g c'est des blanc
derre vidéo c'est des blancs ils sont
trois blancs c'est des blancs je les ai
mis je les ai mis en avant plus cas
raciste c'est de laulation tu prends des
propos tu prend des propos comme quand
il parle comme quand il fait des il fait
d'une certaine manière des statistiques
ethniques mais j suis assez favorable ça
permet de pointer des réalités en aucun
cas il dit tous les musulmans tous les
Arabes sont des délinquants par contre
une grande partie des délinquants une
grande partie une grande partie de la
délinquance dans son établissement il la
cible c'est factuel mais sans aucun cas
raciste c'est simplement factuel par
contre c'est assez malhonnête ce que tu
fais prendre des morceaux de phrases et
dire tu as dit ça j'avais dit ça parce
que tu laisses sousentendre que monsieur
est raciste ou qui tient des propos
islamophobes alors que c'est absolument
faux je t'invite à aller voir ces vidéos
moi je le connais plus ces vidéos moi
j'aimerais